[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god welcome to bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your bible
questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor doug batchelor
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
i don't know if you're aware of the
starlink company founded by elon musk
he's begun the process of launching a
network of as many as 42 000 satellites
to provide low-cost internet to even the
most remote locations on earth
each solar-powered satellite weighs
around 570 pounds and it's about the
same size as a small dining table
this mega constellation of starlink
satellites circling the planet 340 miles
up is meant to carry large amounts of
information rapidly to any point on
earth
it appears that soon the whole world
will be connected to the internet super
highway
this developing picture of international
communication fits perfectly in the
scheme of bible prophecy pastor ross
that's interesting pastor doug
mentioning how that the world is
connected through these satellites that
are being launched and placed in space i
think at the end of the day not only are
people able to log on with their
computers but i think ultimately the
goal would be is to have a cell phone
that is dependent not upon land-based
towers but you can be anywhere and you
can connect directly to a satellite with
your phone and you can talk to somebody
on the other side of the world i
actually know somebody now who has
already signed up for this service and
they're already receiving it but this
pretty long line they just managed to
get to the head of the line and they
said it works
which is you know you've been to our
place in the hills it'll be really
helpful where you're off the grid and
you can still be connected to the world
just think about that
but
you know that also fits in with bible
prophecy because there's some
prophecies that talk about international
communication if you will
you know in the book of revelation
we have in chapter 13 a description of
two powers it's called beast the first
beast that comes from the sea another
beast that comes from the earth
and the bible when talking about these
political and the one is a political
religious power it says in revelation 13
verse 8 it says all who dwell upon the
earth shall worship him whose names have
not been written in the last book of
life
and then in verse 16 of chapter 13 it
says he calls us all both small and
great rich and free slave to receive a
mark in his right hand on his foreheads
so the time is going to come where
through mass communication the world
will be united in
worshiping the speech power except for
those whose names are written in the
last of your life well i think it's
pretty important for us to know what is
that beast power what is the mark of the
beast and even more importantly to know
what is the seal of god
because at the end there's just two
groups those are the mark of the beast
those are the seal of god and it seems
as though communication is going to be
key in getting the whole world together
after all the devil's going to try and
deceive people i think it's going to be
broadcast over the airways and around
the world through satellite but not only
is mass communication used by the devil
in the last days but there's actually
some good news
that's right you can read where jesus
says in matthew 24 verse 14
and this gospel of the kingdom will be
preached in all the world for a witness
to the nations and then the end will
come and so it tells us there'll be a
day when the gospel is going to the
whole world and so it's rather exciting
you know even this broadcast right now
we're streaming around the world through
the internet
and uh there's still some remote
locations that don't get reception but
it looks like uh mr musk is going to
help resolve that
and
uh you know of course we're on tv and by
the way friends we are live tonight and
we've been off the air from our regular
bible answers live program because we've
been doing a
a multi-network broadcast
for what 25 presentations
in the last month
and uh but we expect you we encourage
you to call in with your questions
tonight we are live on bible answers
live we're back in our saddles again
and we have an offer
that has something to do with how do we
know
what the beast is up to and what they're
going to be communicating in the last
days we have a book that's called the
scarlet woman and it ties in with
revelation 17 where you have a woman
representing a church that is
controlling a political power
represented by a beast
and this book tells you all about it
tells you what that political power is
what that religious power is and what's
going to happen according to the book of
revelation what's going to happen is we
near the end of time we will send this
for free to anyone who calls and asks
it's called the scarlet woman and the
number to call for that is 800-835-6747
and again you can just ask for the book
it's called the scarlet woman we'll be
happy to get it in the mail to you if
you're in north america if you're
outside of north america just go to the
amazing facts website it's just
amazingfacts.org
or dot com and you can read the book
there online again if you have a bible
question our phone lines open the number
to call is 800-463-7297
that's
800-463-7297 you might also want to text
your friend and say bible answers live
is live this evening so tune in right
away you can also watch us on amazing
facts tv and of course on the doug
batchelor facebook page the amazing
facts youtube channel so take advantage
of that in addition to just listening on
the radio you can actually participate
with us online absolutely well with that
maybe you can have a word of prayer
we'll go to the phones and see what the
questions are let's do dear father in
heaven again we are so grateful that we
have this opportunity to open up your
word and study it's been a few weeks
that we've had a chance to do this live
and lord we are looking forward to just
allowing your spirit to lead us as we
search the scriptures be with those who
are listening wherever they might be and
guide us a lot as we as we open the
bible in jesus name amen amen
okay well our first caller this evening
is calling from new york we have anthony
anthony welcome to the program you on
the air
hello good evening pastors glad to have
you back thank you it's good to be back
hey good question um
yes so uh
my question has to do with the
commandments um
i you know i've i've heard it said i've
even you know heard you say uh
different times that
um there will be people sincere people
who
did not know the truth about the sabbath
um who didn't have a chance to keep the
sabbath on earth before they died or
before jesus comes and that they will be
in heaven there will be plenty of people
in heaven that did not keep the sabbath
on earth but i wondered does that same
principle apply to the other kents some
something like uh you know people who
worship other gods or the idols or pagan
or people who are you know liars
thieves murderers things like that
does the same principle apply to those
other commandments
yeah i think that uh you can find
examples for
god judges us largely about what we know
and jesus says that and pastor ross
might look up the reference for me at
the times of this ignorance god winked
at
is one that well that's acts 17 30. i'm
pretty sure and the other one is where
jesus said
if you did not know you would have no
sin but since you see your sin remains
and another place christ tells us
he said
god allowed divorce because of the
hardness of your hearts but from the
beginning it was not so so there you can
see that god sometimes has tolerated
some
misguided behavior because people just
didn't understand
it is not god's will for someone to have
more than one wife if i were to take
more than one wife at a time
i mean if you become a widow you can
remarry
but uh
that would be polygamy
and or bigamy if it's two and
that would be a sin and i'd be lost
but you'll have people in heaven that
didn't know that like you know abraham
and jacob and david and many others
because it was just rife during the
times in which they lived
so you know god always wants us to obey
and to follow the holy spirit but there
are areas i think there'll be people in
heaven that maybe did not understand the
commandment about idolatry very devoted
love the lord but they were growing up
in an age where they were surrounded by
idols in church and i think you've got
to be careful not to say that everybody
that attended a church that had idols in
it are statues of mary
that they're all lost
maybe they just didn't understand or
they were misled by priests so i think
god judges everybody on a case-by-case
basis but you know sin is sin and
and the blood of jesus covers those sins
where a person sins and ignorance
just uh the verse you refer to pastor
john 9 41 it says jesus said to them if
you are blind you'd have no sin but now
you say we see therefore your sin
remains
i'm also thinking of another area that
we mentioned those who know the will of
the master and they
they don't do it they beaten with many
stripes those who did not know the will
of the master and did that worthy of
stripes will be beaten with few stripes
so
people are held accountable for what
they know exactly as it comes to this
too much is given much is required
we do have a study guide called written
in stone and it's all about the 10
commandments and we'll be happy to send
this out to anyone who calls and asks
the number again for our free offer is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the study
guide it's called written in stone and
if you have a bible question the number
here in the studio is
is 800-463-7297
adam and eve they uh they suppose they
lost their covering of the light because
they were naked and they had to have fig
leaves
does lucifer still
have wherever
covering a light
when god created him as an archangel
yeah well i don't know the bible ever
tells us lucifer was the archangel
that's a title you only see connected
with michael but to his uh robe
you know the bible if he's still clothed
with light the bible tells us and i
think it's second corinthians 11 that
satan himself can be transformed into an
angel of light
so
uh
angels are ministering spirits they're
different from people like adam and eve
and so you know when adam and eve sinned
they had these robes of light or glory
or something that went out that helped
them to realize that oh something's gone
we're naked
but
angels are really kind of a different
category of creature they are
ministering spirits
and um so i think the devil can
emanate light if he wants the verse
you're referring to second corinthians
chapter 11 verse 14 it says no wonder
for satan himself is transformed into an
angel of light
now you mentioned uh
lucifer is never referred to as the
archangel but he is referred to as the
angel that coverth or the covering which
is a little different than the archangel
okay thanks for call jerry we've got
rodney listening from texas as well
right rodney welcome to the program
hello
hey can you hear me yeah we do thanks
for calling rodney oh yeah while i'm
driving i just wanted to know because i
got a hit sit on
um
yeah
i'm a truck driver and um
my my work sent out a memo saying that
we have to take the vaccine
to stay working here
i was just wondering if there was any
scriptures because
uh
what i understand is they're not giving
anyone
religious excuses not to take the
vaccine
right
but is there any scripture that would
help
talk about that yeah well you're that's
a good question and of course it's a
it's a very relevant question in our
world today
uh
i'll tell you what there's no scripture
that's going to mention vaccine or virus
there are scriptures that say that
medicine there is good medicine and
ezekiel it talks about the leaves of the
tree
uh trees will be from medicine and a
happy heart doeth good like a medicine
and so there are their bible does speak
favorably that there are some good
medicines you have
paul who says luke the beloved physician
is with me
and sometimes physicians would
administer you know herbs or medicines
to help relieve people's suffering
but um so there's no moral problem with
taking a vaccine
and we just want to be clear about that
now there's a there's another issue that
you're alluding to in this
and that's
you know
at what point it's almost like a
political question with patriotism at
what point does is the government
overstepping its bounds
in requiring people to
uh to take something
um
and you know i've thought a lot about
this because we get a lot of questions
and by the way there there are some
companies that are providing in some
states it varies from state to state are
providing religious exemptions
and you know pastor ross and i we
support people's decisions if if they
want to take the vaccine if they don't
we believe in freedom
um you know i think it's we're not
doctors so we don't
uh issue medical advice
and we're not uh experts in the
constitution or politicians we're
pastors
but um
so that may vary from state to state we
have written a few letters to people
explaining that you know we've got a
member of the church and for some health
reason they're asking if
they might get an exemption for a
religious conviction or a health reason
and some have been accepted some have
not i think it varies from from company
to company
but um
for me i thought a lot about this
and i
you know
in our culture today
there's an element of risk
in life
and every culture decides you know how
much risk they're willing to accept
to have freedom
and
for example i don't drink
pasta ross i think it's safe to say
doesn't drink alcohol
people have a right to drink alcohol in
our country even though we know
that a certain number of those people
are going to get sick or make other
people sick or have accidents and we say
look we're going to respect their right
even though we know there's a risk
involved i think smoking is a very bad
idea but it's still legal to smoke and
the government of course accepts tax
money from that
and so the culture has accepted a
certain amount of risk to allow that
freedom and so i think one of the
questions that some people are grappling
with is not you know whether the bible
forbids it but they're wondering about
at what point
are we um uh for the illusion of
security are we taking away freedoms
and so that's i think another very
important issue but
we can't really give you a scripture on
vaccine well you know pastor you do
mention something that's maybe worth
just referencing as far as the bible
goes if you look at end time events book
revelation talks about a time where
it's not a vaccine that's false but it
is a form of worship that's forced
and eventually people can't buy and sell
if they refuse to go along with this
this law dealing with worship it is
interesting that when people are afraid
they are willing to you know 9 11 and
onwards when people are afraid they're
willing to surrender their rights very
quickly for security for the illusion of
security at least the illusion of that
but at some point you know it seems as
though things go from bad to worse
uh the only thing that you end up
gaining is just a loss of freedoms at
the end you don't really gain that
security or that safety that people are
looking for so it is an interesting
question and of course it's it's playing
out today but um i think individually we
need to we need to make decisions based
on health reasons if a person is a
high-risk category they need to talk to
their doctors they need to figure out
what's the best thing for them to do and
it's not as you mentioned pasadena it's
not a
the bible doesn't speak against it and
the bible doesn't speak for it the bible
does say that your body is the temple of
the holy spirit so you want to take care
of yourself the best you can yeah and
there's no moral dilemma with taking a
vaccine
you know there there's been a lot of
plagues and things that have been stayed
by you know like smallpox or polio or
other things that have been eradicated
by health measures so and the bible
talks about
sanitation the bible even talks about
if there's something contagious how to
deal with that
well we can go on and on this is a very
a very relevant question but we have
some other people lined up thanks so
much appreciate that rodney thanks
rodney we've got randy listening in
indiana randy welcome to the program
good evening how are you hi randy we're
we're getting a lot of road noise so
maybe you could state your question and
then we're going to answer by muting you
copy that
um my question
if a is survives or endures
to the end
the bible says he who endures to the end
he will be saved
can that person still even though the
university then be
lost okay thank you i think you're
quoting from matthew 24 where jesus is
describing the persecution of god's
people in the last days
and jesus talks about a great
tribulation such as there never has been
and he says that um but he that endures
to the to the end will be saved those
people who are god's elect that are
faithful enduring to the end they are
saved
and so um when you talk about enduring
to the end he's not talking about
enduring trial or torture he's talking
about their faith endures to the end
they are obviously saved and we have a
group described in revelation chapter
seven it talks about those who have the
seal of god in their foreheads well if
you have the seal of god means you
surrender to him and and he's going to
take care of you during the tribulation
you need not fear so
if we surrender our life to christ every
day we're going to receive that seal and
we need not fear when the time of
trouble comes that's right
thanks for your call we're going to go
to e frank now in new york e frank
you're on the air
yes uh good evening pastor doug and and
pastor ross
my question for you gentlemen this
evening is
as follows
did uh jesus uh
resurrect on the third day
in his full glory and were there any
eyewitnesses according to scripture
that saw jesus going to heaven directly
after the third day or was it a 40-day
period of ascension
because i'm a little bit confused how
jesus
rose on the third day and then
he stood on earth for 40 days and then
he went in to heaven uh 40 days later
uh
and scripture never stated if they
actually saw jesus go into heaven
directly
all right i think that if you look in
the gospel of john chapter 20. it tells
us that
after the angel came and threw away the
stone
the roman guard that was there guarding
the tomb they saw the angels and they
fled in fear
first they fell down as though they were
dead and then they fled
and when the women came they saw two
angels
the stone was rolled away
they left to go tell the others and mary
was there by herself weeping she stayed
that's where you pick up the story in
john 20 verse 11 mary stood outside the
tomb weeping
jesus appears to her
she goes to grab his feet and worship
him and he says do not cling to me this
is verse 17 for i have not yet ascended
to my father but go to my brethren and
say i am ascending to my father and to
your father to my god and your god
later that day when he sees them they
worship him so between the time he saw
mary she
he waited for mary he revealed himself
said go tell the disciples and peter i'm
alive
and that evening meeting when he says
all hail he invites their worship he
ascended to heaven and came back again
to have his sacrifice declared
successful and victorious and
and time in heaven can be different than
time on earth it may have been 20 hours
up there and seemed like four hours here
i don't know
nothing's too hard for the lord when you
study
the theory of relativity and time travel
but
so then jesus continued to go to and
from heaven and appeared to the
disciples on earth over a period of 40
days when he made his final ascent
the way i understand it and in 10 days
before pentecost
and he ascended somewhere by bethany
with many witnesses at least the 12
apostles were witnessing that in acts
chapter acts chapter 1
verse 12.
actually verse 9. right so i think the
lord you know he was not restricted to
heaven or earth he was going to and from
heaven from the time of his resurrection
until his final ascension
um
[Music]
in acts one like i said 40 days after
so hopefully that made sense you frank
all right thanks jokoli frank we got
tony listening in indiana tony welcome
to the program
hello thank you i have a question about
uh
the queen of sheba giving king solomon
666 talents of gold and legend is that
he committed adultery with her and had a
child
and is there a literal connection to
prostitution in the mark of the beast
beyond just selfishness and the ten
commandments
all right well when you talk about the
queen of sheba the the notion and you'll
find this in first kings chapter 10.
uh
and sheba was a country that was you
know probably
somewhere in the vicinity of saudi
arabia or
um could have been ethiopian they're not
sure but it calls her jesus refers to
her as the queen of the south
and it says the queen of the south will
stand in judgment of this generation she
came a great distance to hear the wisdom
of solomon and jesus said now a greater
than solomon is here
and so um
jesus speaks of her in a very positive
way
the idea that she had an affair with
solomon there's not a shred a thread of
anything in the bible that hints of that
she came with purely alteristic motives
of seeking wisdom and solomon answered
her questions and
and she gave a gift it was customary
that when you go visit a king you give a
gift and if royalty visits royalty it's
a big gift
i do think the number 666 is interesting
because
when you read the account of solomon
everything continues to go from glory to
glory until you get to chapter
and right after it says he received 666
talents
you then read in the next chapter but
solomon loved many foreign women now it
mentions the women but it never mentions
the queen of sheba
the this was the daughter of pharaoh and
the moabites and and hittites
these are local women he ended up
intermarrying with never says anything
about having a marriage or an affair i
mean he had 300 wives and
what was it 600 wives 300 concubines
he didn't need one more
uh and you know we don't know she might
have been 70 years old the bible doesn't
tell us anything
about
this was an official state visit i think
the point it's even mentioned is that
solomon's fame not only reached to the
area close to israel but his fame had
reached all the way down to quite
possibly ethiopia to the queen of sheba
and she said i've got to come see for
myself yeah i've got to see if these
things are so so it was an official
state visit and she was amazed not so
much by the majesty of jerusalem and
solomon and the wealth but just the
wisdom and the god that he worshipped
and everything looked really good in the
story of israel until you hear that
number 666 and then it says but he loved
many form and the kingdom starts going
south pardon me for the pun starts going
bad direction after that number so that
i always thought was interesting and
probably not a coincidence hey thank you
eric i hope that made some sense all
right we've got jill listening from
florida jill welcome to the program you
on the air
yes hi uh pastors how are you tonight
fine thank you jill i appreciate your
calling
um i have a question i i don't know if
i'm wording this right but when god
created adam and eve um what color were
they because i'm trying to find out it's
how did all these races come to be if
they were just a certain color
you know a good answer for that question
is
the same answer when people say where
did all the languages come from there's
so many different languages what
language did adam and eve speak
um well adam and eve probably spoke a an
original tongue and everything we talked
we use now as sort of like fragments of
that original language of canaan and
eden
so at the tower of babel when everybody
was scattered
different groups stayed together and
through intermarriage within a smaller
pool a smaller gene pool
different genetic traits became
predominant and so some have said well
the three
that the three children of noah formed
the three rager three major races of the
world i've heard people say that before
it's really that's not true at all
that you know the lord no i had three
kids and one was black and one was white
and one was asian or something like that
i've actually heard that
but
it the division didn't really happen
until the tower of babel the same time
the languages were divided
and you even see this with animals
around the world you're going to see a
difference in the canines that you find
in america than the ones you're going to
find like the the african wolves those
they're spotted black and white dogs
yeah and then you got hyenas and then
you come to america you get the coyotes
and you go well because they're kind of
isolated they they breed and certain
genetic traits become prominent what
color were adam and eve
probably like a
a melding of all i don't know that would
be tan or something i'm not sure
i think i think the word adam is like
the word edom it means ruddy or reddish
is what i've heard but
i know that's what the word means but i
can't picture adam being red you know
the interesting thing is that god gave
uh in creating adam and eve he gave
incredible a diversity within the gene
poll so that there is a certain degree
of adaptation to the environment where
they went yeah those who went to hotter
areas their skin color began to change
to help with the heat those who went to
cold areas their skin became
lighter to absorb more sunlight and so
all of that was was built into the genes
of adam and eve for all the different
groups and all of the different races
that we see today it's amazing yeah
and the people who were native to the
areas around the equator are a lot less
susceptible to
skin cancer from the sun
you know the god gave them some
mechanisms to resist that
all right i hope that helps a little bit
we appreciate your question jill
you know pastor we're coming up on a
break yeah we're going to take a break
we don't have another question until
after the break so friends don't go away
we're going to be right back if you have
a bible question then i'm going to call
is
nine 800-463-7297 and right after the
break we will take more of your bible
questions we'll be right back
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
did you know that noah was present at
the birth of abraham
ok maybe he wasn't in the room
but he was alive and probably telling
stories about his floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of revelation
biblehistory.com is a free resource
where you can explore major bible events
and characters enhance your knowledge of
the bible and draw closer to god's word
go deeper visit biblehistory.com
[Music]
amazingfacts offers some of the best
christian resources for all ages we hope
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the lord
what does bible prophecy reveal about
the world's two largest religions
explore the ancient conflict in islam
christianity and prophecy a compelling
three-part series with pastor doug
batchelor
get yours today by calling 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
what if you could know the future
what would you
do what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a military prodigy
150 years in advance
cyrus had been named
nebuchadnezzar who built the city as a
showcase to the entire world
rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
[Music]
this intriguing documentary hosted by
pastor doug batchelor explores the most
striking bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history
kingdoms in time
an extraordinary adventure through the
bible's most amazing fulfilled
prophecies kingdoms in time.com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
[Music]
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
this is where we have the most fun bible
answers live friends we are here to do
our best to answer any bible question
you might have or questions about living
the christian life we're broadcasting
not only on radio we're on amazing facts
television and we're adding tv stations
as time goes by we're on satellite radio
across the country
and the internet where you can listen on
the doug batchelor facebook page the
amazing facts facebook page the amazing
facts youtube channel and my name is
doug batchelor my name is john ross and
friends we're ready to go to the phone
lines again if you have a bible question
you might be wondering what's the number
it's 800-463-7297
get you right in here to our studio we
have uh shawanda listening from
mississippi shawanda welcome to the
program
thank you
um my question is according to
the parable of the sore
in mark
luke 8 and matthew 13 where it talks
about the seed was on 4
or 3 ground the stoney the thorny and
there was one ground that produces good
fruit
30 60 100 fold so my question is what
happens to those who produce
who who don't produce
the sony and the thorny ground is it
either loss of reward
or do are they literally banished out of
the kingdom well the first one is the
seed that falls on the pathway
it's not the the stony ground or the
shallow ground
and the ravens snatch it away and jesus
later explains that when some people
hear the word the devil then comes
and takes it out of their heart so that
they become unproductive
but um
what's your understanding of that pastor
ross yeah absolutely you know we got
this the seed is the word
and the grounds represent the hearts
that receive the word
so we want to be the fruitful ground
that produces a harvest those who have
stony ground it means their hearts are
not right for the gospel
unfortunately some have rejected the
gospel because they've held into the
things of this world
and ultimately it has cost them their
salvation
is that answering your question a little
bit shawanda
uh well
yes and um well the thorny ground is my
question like they're producing
i mean they receive the word but then if
cares is the lie it cares in this life
and things come in to choke the word
that it's unfruitful is that just a loss
of reward or are these are these
literally not entering to the kingdom
those those people who the word was
received but the care that everything in
life just choked out the word they were
they were unfruitful are they just not
entering into the kingdom of god in yeah
i think that in the parable there's only
one out of the four
that is described as saved the other
ones become distracted with the world or
they they spring up and then they they
wither soon because they have no root
the only one that really thrives and is
alive is the fourth category you know
jesus said he that endures to the end
shall be saved so there needs to be a
an endurance it's not good enough just
to receive christ as your personal
savior and then allow the world to crowd
him out we want to receive christ and
hold on to him that's why the apostle
paul said i die daily so it's a day by
day experience where we come to christ
and we ask for forgiveness and we
receive his grace and we trust in him so
it's not a one-time thing
if it's a one-time experience then that
experience could very well be over
choked or overcome by the cares of this
world so we want to be that fruitful
soil
all right thanks you're cool shawanda
appreciate that we have ellen listening
in new mexico ellen welcome to the
program
hi
i wondered if you could explain to me
what the
references in the bible to the towers
falling did that have anything to do
with the twin towers
um
no i don't think so and there is a
passage in uh i don't know if it's
talking in the question i think you
mentioned judges but
in the book of isaiah
it talks about i think it's isaiah where
it says the towers fall
but uh
they had watch towers in all of the
capitals and isaiah often a lot of his
prophecies have to do with the fall of
jerusalem to the babylonians because of
their unfaithfulness
and the walls were destroyed and the
towers fell
there is a time where talks about jesus
refers to a tower that fell on those of
siloam
and
18 men were killed and but i don't think
those are talking about 9 11. not
specifically but i think the principles
that we find that as we near the end of
time judgment will increase just like
judgment that came upon sodom and
gomorrah and these other sinful cities i
think as we near the end of time the
cities are going to become
judged to some degree
and the wickedness that is so ripe in
the cities and god in his mercy is still
allowing a certain degree of protection
and freedom but just in the last year
pastor that we've seen an increase of
violence in the cities and i think that
is to some degree a warning for
believers yeah and the first i think
she's talking about is isaiah 30 verse
25 it says there will be on every high
mountain on every high hill rivers and
streams of waters in the day of great
slaughter when the towers fall
and so some have looked at that passage
that verse there and they said oh that's
talking about the twin towers well
in world war one with the bombing a lot
of towers fell in world war ii a lot of
towers fell
and this was another example of a
judgment or a you know certainly a trial
when the towers fell
i don't think isaiah was specifically
talking about 911 here and i think the
tower in that context is a military
tower it's part of a stronghold or a
city not not a financial building yep
there you go that good good answer all
right well thank you for your call ellen
we've got uh marquise listening from
indiana marquis welcome to the program
hey how you guys doing today doing well
thanks for calling all right my question
thank you my question comes from um john
chapter 21 verse 15
when jesus asked simon he said son he
said simon son of jonah do you love me
more than these was that the same jonah
that was mentioned in the old testament
uh no but
in the new testament there are a number
of people that were named after old
testament heroes
and jonah was of course a very popular
old testament character
and peter's father was evidently named
jonah
and so jesus referred to him as
peter the son of jonah or peter barjona
barming son of
jesus was called jesus the son of joseph
and so it's not the jonah from the old
testament this is peter's father
jonah was a very common name it means
dove
and
so
yeah
same name different people you've got
several people in the bible that uh have
similar names there's more than one
person named moses there's several
people named john there's even two or
three name jesus
it's interesting you've got saul who
converts and becomes paul but if you
look at the old testament character of
saul it's probably not somebody you want
to name your son after yeah and yet saul
was a popular name at least as far as we
know of back in bible times well he was
good for a while yeah he was he was all
right thanks for call marquis we got
barbara listening in sacramento
california barbara welcome to the
program
oh thank you pastor um my question is
i'm i'm
thinking god said when god sent his
beloved son to earth
to suffer and die for us and i cannot
visualize
a loving father
sending his son
to suffer and i'm wondering why god
himself didn't just come down to suffer
for us why did he send someone he loved
well it's not that god the father
ordered his son
the father and the son seen the dilemma
of mankind and they knew the only way to
redeem mankind was if one of them
paid and by the way
all three
of them suffered god the father the son
and the holy spirit all suffered equally
in some ways you'd think the father
suffered more
any parent when you see your children
suffering seriously you'd often say i
would trade places with them rather than
see them suffer
so
this was done it was a cooperative
decision
and keep in mind
we broke the law of the creator the
bible tells us that all things that were
created were created by jesus the son
and so here you've got the creator
dying for his creation
and
the father allowing that you know he so
loved the world he gave his son
you know pastor that was the point i was
just going to mention is that famous
verse for god so of the world that he
gave his only begotten son it wasn't a
requirement the father didn't say all
right son you need to go
but out of love for us he gave his son
what a sacrifice so
the father suffered and the son and you
know just speaking from a parent's
perspective how hard it must have been
for god the father to witness what they
did to his son
and to go through all of that just
without a doubt the father suffered
greatly because of man's sin yeah
absolutely does that help barbara
yes it does but now you just brought up
another question i thought god didn't
have any emotions so how could he
suffer no why would you think god has no
emotions
well how how could he
i mean he is god he just
well the bible says you know we're made
in god's image
and we are fraught with emotions and god
the bible says has joy the bible says
god sings we get our emotions from him
we're made in his image the bible tells
us there's god has anger he has wrath he
has jealousy
he says i'm a jealous god
so
you know every spectrum of emotion
people have but now god's emotions are
only going to be in harmony with
uh good
sometimes we'll have misplaced jealousy
or misplaced emotions you know gods are
always coming from love and love love
congratulations yeah absolutely so yes
god does definitely does have feelings
and jesus loves us desperately there's a
verse in the bible in deuteronomy 5
where god says oh
i just said phrase he says oh and even
where it says in john 3 16 god so loved
the world
you know that that phrase kind of
denotes passion
and he says oh that there was such a
heart in them that they would fear me
and keep my commandments always and in
genesis god says it broke god's heart
that he made man
and he said i'm going to clean the earth
from them except for noah so yeah god
you see the passion of god even in the
old testament pastor you've got god
saying oh turn turn why will you perish
and yeah crying out saying please so
without a doubt some beautiful emotion
displayed in the bible all right well
thank you for your call barbara we're
going to go to uh kathy in tennessee
kathy welcome to the program
hi can you hear me we do loud and clear
okay wonderful um
well thanks to facebook i'm calling you
guys this evening
surprisingly
but i don't think by accident
so my question is
around
receiving the gifts of the spirit i
don't have scripture to offer you
only a question and hoping that you can
provide me perhaps with some living
guidance
scripturally based
as this actually happened to me
about a year ago
very unexpectedly
i found myself praying
one day and i was i i wound up in i
wound up speaking in tongues and it was
utterly overwhelming
not something i've ever aspired to do
not something i've ever known anyone to
do i didn't even know what it sounded
like or looked like and then there i was
doing it
um
and what's the best way to
process that
receive that and shepherd it
and then beyond that what is going on
in the world today is there a
abundant outpouring of this spirit going
on because the same thing happened to my
aunt
about the same time it happened to me
well you attend church
i do i i'm not going as regularly as i
used to i've been slow to get back in
okay
but i do all right so the church that
you go to do the people there believe in
and practice praying in tongues no
no this is a little unusual for your
church even very yeah it's it's unusual
for any and this has never happened to
anyone in my family that i know of and
really no one else that i know all right
well let's talk about that for just a
minute now if you're wanting to process
if what i'm doing is right or wrong or
what to do with it first place you want
to look is in the word
so in the word jesus is our example
do you find an example where jesus prays
in tongues in the bible
um well i guess i need to look no well
i'm i guess i'll give you the answer the
answer is no
um okay there the there's three examples
of speaking in tongues in the bible it's
acts chapter 2 acts chapter 10 and acts
chapter 19.
now when i first became a christian i'm
just you asking i'm telling you honestly
i first became a christian i worship
with charismatic christians and all of
my friends spoken tongues and they
wanted to encourage me to speak in
tongues and pray in tongues
and i kept thinking well am i missing
something so i i spent a lot of time
studying this because i i certainly
wanted the baptism of the holy spirit
it's not uncommon that some people have
been praying and they're so overcome
with emotions that they're at a loss of
words and they may
break out in some unintelligible speech
and it sounds like what you're saying
has happened
uh sometimes yeah you can't find words
and
but now there's no meaning to what
you're saying
in other words if you say well what
exactly did i just say you probably
couldn't interpret that
is that right no
no i had no idea what i was saying so
the bible says we should pray in the
spirit but we should pray with the
understanding so if you're praying a
prayer you would want to know what am i
asking and how do you know if you get an
answer
can i we have a book that we'd like to
send you i think that would
it free and it'll help answer that and
any of your friends that are listening
that have a similar question yeah all
you need to do kathy is call
800-835-6747 that is a free resource
phone line again you'll see it if you're
watching on facebook it's on the screen
800-835-6747 as for the book it's called
understanding tongues that'll give you a
lot of scriptures and i think you'll
find this book to be enlightening as you
compare with what the bible says and
it'll kind of bring into perspective uh
your experience so take a look at that
call again
800-835-6747 ask for the book
understanding tongues and we'll be happy
to send it to you right away
again thank you for calling
we've got uh let's see we'll go to
bridget actually we go to julia next in
michigan julia welcome to the program
hi
hi hi
i have a question i'm reading um
and what i'm reading through the bible
okay and i'm i'm doing a walk through
the bible by hms richard yeah
my wife's done the same study it's a
good one yeah okay
so all right i'm and i'm into ezekiel um
um 40 and 41 and it talks about
another temple
that was going to be built while it was
described by ezekiel
and um it was described in a lot of
detail
um that he he talked about but that it
was never built
um so my question is
approximately
about what time would that have been
built if it happened and then
because
hms puts in there that he says that it
was would have been a fourth temple
but there were then solomon's
and then zerubbabels
but zerubbabel's temple was added on by
herod so really that was a third temple
or a second temple
so it would have been a third temple
yeah well no it would have been a fourth
if if it had been built but
let me just this is a mysterious chapter
matter of fact it's not only in chapter
40 he references this temple all the way
through the end of his book
you've got the first temple being the
one in the wilderness it was a portable
tabernacle but it was considered a
temple so you got that one then you have
solomon's temple then you have zero
bubbles temple that was modified by
herod and so um i think hms richards was
saying
this if it had been built when they came
back from the babylonian captivity its
dimensions were bigger it would have
been a fourth there are two theories two
principle theories about what is
ezekiel's temple he goes to great length
and give detail about it the rooms and
the size and it's all measured and an
angel showing them all this
some have said well if they had been
obedient
god would have given them independence
again and this would have been the
international temple for the nation
so that's one theory the other theory is
since the new testament tells us that
jesus said destroy this temple made with
hands and i'll make one without hands
and he's talking about his body the
church
and the bible says the church we are
living stones that we are a temple of
god
that ezekiel is using symbolic language
to talk about god's church
and um which you know adds another layer
of questions what what all those
measurements and things mean
so we actually have a study that amazing
facts has done on secrets of the
sanctuary
that
you might
you might enjoy looking at where we talk
about some of the symbolism in the
sanctuary services that teaches us about
the plan of salvation
and you're thinking about the magazine
that we have dealing with sanctuary yeah
yep
and we did a series on the sanctuary
that we recorded this year that's right
it's part of our afco program it's
called amazing sanctuaries it deals with
the sanctuary and different themes and
if you'd like to learn more about that
for this one you'll probably need to go
to the amazing facts website just
amazingfacts.coma.org
type in there yep divine design is the
name of the magazine and you'll be able
to find out more information about that
we've got marvins who is listening from
canada marvin's welcome to the program
hello both of you
evening
yeah your question
yeah how you are good my name is marvin
and i'm from mutual canada okay
uh i have a question for you and first
of all i'm not very good at speaking
english so i hope you will understand my
question so far so good
thank you
mr lord
um according to matthew 27 versus verse
52 53 i will read for you
um and the grease we opened and many
bodies of the saints who had fallen
asleep were raised
and 53 and coming out of the grave after
his resurrection about jesus they went
into the holy city and april to mini
so my question is
why some older people uh the people
why some holy people rise up after the
racist resurrection of him
while he said that people will only only
rise up of the end of the world
okay so good question we understand
there's a special resurrection that
happens at the time of christ's death
during the earthquake during the time of
his crucifixion the graves were split
open
and then it tells us that when he rose
these
there's a small group it's not uh not
not thousands but there were many of the
saints who had slept that were brought
out of their graves and taken as a first
fruit to heaven
and the bible says when he ascended on
high he led captivity captive and gave
gifts unto men
and that is a reference to christ's
ascension when he ascended to heaven
those who were resurrected at the time
of christ's resurrection ascended as
first fruits of a much bigger
resurrection that would occur at the
second coming of christ so who's in
heaven now or past the day you've got
enoch you've got elijah you've got moses
who was resurrected and taken to heaven
and then you have this group we don't
know how many are in the group but there
is a group that was resurrected name
heaven now and then the rest will of
course be resurrected at the second
coming yeah in the hebrew economy
whenever they had a harvest they would
take a handful they called it a sheaf
you know they would harvest the grain
and kind of bind up a sheaf that could
be carried
like we have bales of hay and they would
present that to the lord it's like jesus
took a trophy a sheaf a first fruit
to heaven of those who will be redeemed
at the final resurrection
but thank you we appreciate that marvins
i hope that helps a little bit
we've got uh alencio from california
alencia welcome to the program
yes hi welcome uh i just have one
question um
and it's it's kind of a filled question
um
and i've heard both sides whether the
calvinistic reformed
biblical interpretation is more biblical
than
the armenian
side whether it's solely on
predestination or solely based on the
free will and i have questions in my own
reference to like you know romans 9
ephesians 1 and like ezekiel talks about
how god takes the heart of stone and
makes a heart of flesh so i don't know
if that happens before and if that is
necessary for someone to have faith or
is it solely
like
from my understanding what armenians are
saying
it's just solely your faith if you just
have faith in what the gospel says then
that's what it is or did christ die for
his people alone and only his sheep all
right you well you've you have opened
the big box of christian questions right
there
uh and for our friends that are
listening the one of the great debates
among christians uh you might call it
you know predestination and free will
you've got you know john wesley on one
side and george whitefield on the other
where uh you know calvin
and uh arminius is where you get
arminianism calvinism and the idea is uh
has god did jesus only die for the ones
that are saved or did he die for
everybody
we believe that bible says christ died
for all and that means all
not all took advantage of that great
sacrifice
and then the other question that's in
that question is
that
does the lord just a point from heaven
who's going to be saved and they really
have no will or choice in the matter and
you know armenian christians believe
well
or you might even have baptists that are
called free will baptists they believe
in
people who have a choice
to say that humans have no choice
and the majority of people will be lost
we you know jesus says broad is a way
that leads to destruction
that implies that god made a lot of
creatures
that have no choice but to sin and then
he's going to punish them for sinning
so that almost would make god sound like
an accomplice in the sin and that he
makes creatures said i'm not going to
give you an opportunity to be saved or
have a change of heart or you don't even
have a choice but i'm going to punish
you for sinning
you know pastor i think with some of the
confusion is when you look at some of
those passages in the new testament it
talks about god predestinating some
people think well as that has to do with
salvation no it's not a predestination
for salvation but it is god who chose
who predestined israel
to be the people through whom the
messiah would come
and that was a choice that god made so
there is a distinction between
individual predestination versus a
nation being chosen by god for a
specific purpose right and that's where
the confusion comes in of course
individually god wants each of us to
choose to serve him and it's the
goodness of god that leads us to
repentance we can't repent without the
spirit of god but that spirit is
available to all because he's not
willing that any should perish but shall
all should come to salvation exactly
people do have the freedom to make
decisions and to process you know the
longer i've spent time studying this
the more i've come to believe that the
truth actually lies somewhere in the
middle
in that there's no doubt that god is
involved in drawing us so he is he's
expressing his sovereignty in drawing
the heart but we must respond to that
drawing and he does give us freedom
because you can't love if you're
pre-programmed to love it's forced
well friends yeah thank you i hope that
helps a little bit we do have a free
offer that talks about can a save man be
lost
if you'd like that um
the gentleman you just called alicia
yep yeah you will uh just go to the
amazing facts website or you can just
call 800-835-6747
and ask for the book it's called can a
save man choose to be lost and it's
filled with great scripture yeah now for
our friends that are listening we sign
off actually on our satellite time uh a
little sooner but then we stay on macy's
facts television and most of our
land-based stations and we kind of go
through some rapid fire bible questions
for about two minutes i also want to
thank all those who joined us for the
panorama of prophecy programs that were
going on from october 15 to november
and those programs are still online if
you did not get to see them simply go to
the website that is panorama of
prophecy.com
and you can still watch the archives of
the programs we recorded in the last
month matter of fact last program was
yesterday yesterday
we'll be back in a moment for those who
stand by
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
did you know that noah was present at
the birth of abraham
ok maybe he wasn't in the room
but he was alive and probably telling
stories about his floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of revelation
biblehistory.com is a free resource
where you can explore major bible events
and characters enhance your knowledge of
the bible and draw closer to god's word
go deeper
visit biblehistory.com
amazingfacts offers some of the best
christian resources for all ages we hope
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the lord
what does bible prophecy reveal about
the world's two largest religions
explore the ancient conflict in islam
christianity and prophecy a compelling
three-part series with pastor doug
batchelor
get yours today by calling
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
hello friends we want to welcome you
back to our special
question section we look forward to this
we got two minutes past it and we're
going to try and answer as many
questions as we can these are questions
that folks have emailed two amazing
facts and if you want to email us a
question it's just simply bal questions
at
amazingfacts.org all right question
number one when lucifer was cast out of
heaven was this before or after earth
was created that's revelation chapter 12
and we believe that was before that war
in heaven was before the creation of the
world and as satan went roaming through
the universe trying to recruit support
he then came to our planet shortly after
we've been created but he was cast out
first okay question number two is it
possible to hasten god's second coming
uh peter tells us that um
as we share the gospel it says we look
forward to and hasten the coming of the
lord so christ said that after the
gospel goes to all the world then the
end will come we can participate in
taking the gospel to all the world and
so in a secondary sense we're helping to
hasten that okay next question that we
have luke 17 matthew 24 says two men
will be in one bed the one taking the
other left two women grinding at the
mill one taking the other left is
talking about a secret rapture
uh well he is talking about when the
lord comes but he's not talking about a
secret rapture because the disciples ask
in the same passage where meaning where
are they taken and jesus says wherever
the eagles the vultures are or where the
body is that's where the vultures gather
together and so it sounds like the ones
who are taken are taken away in judgment
it talks about the wicked who the flood
came and took them away
children of israel would disobey and
they were carried away to babylon or
assyria so some folks have totally
misunderstood this passage and i don't
think it's talking about the secret
rapture talk about two classes the saved
and the lost all right well thank you
friends again for your questions we look
forward to seeing you next week on
another live bible answer live until
then god bless
[Music]
you